[Music]
all of you are dangerous
that's why you're here
[Music]
do you know what mutants are hey
let me go this isn't a hospital
it's a cage
we can get out of this
what's going on everybody it's warren
and in a very
interesting and weird turn of events it
has been announced that
the new mutants is going straight to
disney plus
on september 4th now there was a ton
of debate about this this morning on
whether or not this was real or
fake and as it stands right now it seems
to be
real and there are a few key reasons why
so just for context this was aired
only in australia and one point is that
it has
never before seen footage in it this
footage is
literally nowhere to be found it is
brand new
also the advertising before the
announcement that new mutants is coming
to streaming plus
on the tv is a real australian ad
also the m at the bottom left of the tv
is the australian rating for mature
which is a rating that the new mutants
will have
and since this was recorded by somebody
simply recording their tv
it's really hard to fake especially with
the ads in it and
never before seen footage for the new
mutants
and to top it all off not to mention
disney plus the new mutants at comic con
had
supposedly a really really big
announcement coming up
so it does seem like this is real it
just somehow
got leaked somebody over in australia
made a mistake and aired it too early
now for those of you who have heard that
disney has apparently denied this being
true
well just for reference when things
leaked for solo
they denied that being true as well and
then the movie came out and they ended
up being true
so if disney somehow made a mistake and
aired this when they weren't supposed to
they're not going to admit that they
made a mistake and that this is real
and the reason is because they have a
big announcement coming up for the new
mutants planned already to announce that
it's going straight to streaming
so everything points to this being true
and
disney has their big announcement for
the new mutants scheduled for
thursday so i'm expecting them to
officially announce that the new mutants
are coming to streaming on the 4th
of september they're just denying it
right now so they can announce it
themselves on thursday but
we will wait and see so we'll have to
wait till comic con at home
but let me know what you think would you
like the new mutants to go straight to
streaming or do we want to wait
a lot longer for it to hit the theaters
let me know what you think in the
comments down below
and don't forget to subscribe to stay up
to date on all things relating to the
mcu and so you can enter this week's
giveaway for a chance to win a hawkeye
funko pop for live updates you can
follow me on twitter and as always thank
you all so much for watching woof